[Aplausos]
[Música]
hungría es como rusia pero baja en
calorías tienen corrupción sí pero no
llegar al nivel de rusia es un gobierno
autoritario pues si cada vez más pero
tampoco llegan al nivel de envenenar a
los opositores políticos con no me choca
no deja de ser un país de la unión
europea es decir con unas mínimas
garantías democráticas el presidente de
hungría es este señor que veis en
pantalla viktor orbán el principal
aliado de vladimir putin en europa
podríamos decir que orbán es algo así
como el enfant terrible de bruselas
autoritario ultra conservador y ahora
mismo pro pudin hasta la muerte vamos lo
que viene siendo un partidazo y ya sé lo
que estaréis pensando muchos este vídeo
va a ser una crítica sin sentido a
víctor haro en verdad por alguna razón
recibimos muchísimos comentarios que nos
acusan de estar financiados por george
soros y como todo el mundo sabe orbán es
el archienemigo de soros así que blanco
y en botella seguro que este vídeo está
apagado por soros para que mostremos las
vergüenzas del presidente de hungría
verdad paréntesis alguna veces habéis
preguntado por qué george soros es tan
conocido pues al final de este vídeo os
lo contaremos pero lo cierto es que
siento decepcionados pero en el vídeo de
hoy no vamos a insultar a orbán es más
vamos a centrarnos en la otra cara de
hungría y de que otra cara de hungría
estamos hablando pues de esto viktor
orbán gana por cuarta vez consecutiva a
las elecciones para primer ministro de
hungría habéis oído bien cuatro
victorias electorales consecutivas
viktor orbán lleva más de doce años en
el poder y cada vez que va a las urnas
arrasa
[Música]
ojo porque estas últimas elecciones de
2022 tienen un mérito especial porque en
este caso casi todos los partidos
políticos desde la extrema derecha hasta
los socialdemócratas se aliaron en una
coalición improbable para intentar
derrotar le resultado no sólo al ganado
es que ha ganado por mayoría absoluta
otra vez en otras palabras quería ganar
unas elecciones poned un orbán en
vuestras mirar este hombre es que hasta
gana las elecciones para presidente de
la comunidad de vecinos es una cosa
increíble y si habéis oído bien gana las
elecciones porque como hemos dicho antes
hungría es como rusia pero baja en
calorías y esto significa que las
elecciones son relativamente libres
cierto es que el partido de orbán el
fidesz ha hecho algunas pequeñas trampas
pero hay que reconocer la realidad como
es orbán no necesita maquillar los datos
es realmente popular en su país la
pregunta es porque cuál es el secreto
detrás del éxito electoral de viktor
orbán hay alguna lección que podamos
aprender de hungría y por qué george
soros y es tan conocido en todo el mundo
hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes antes sabéis cómo podéis
apoyar a visual polític de forma pues
está clarísimo entrando en nuestra
comunidad de patrián no solo estaréis
contribuyendo a que visual político siga
adelante además tendréis acceso a
merchandising como esta camiseta que
llevo puesta que veis aquí la única
forma de conseguirla es formando parte
de nuestra comunidad porque no está a la
venta pero no sólo eso también tenemos
una newsletter semanal las claves de la
semana donde tratamos temas que no nos
da tiempo a cubrir en forma de vídeos
además también estamos subiendo
contenido exclusivo por ejemplo ahí es
donde hemos publicado otro vídeo donde
nos centramos en hungría y george soros
donde profundizamos en temas que no nos
va a dar tiempo a cubrir en este vídeo
así que ya sabéis si nos lo queréis
perder os espero en la comunidad de
visual política en patrio ni ahora si
vamos a ver un poco de historia
[Música]
es la economía estúpido
con un software que se llamara chica si
trabajáis en algo relacionado con la
arquitectura seguro que lo habéis
utilizado alguna vez es uno de los
software de referencia en esta industria
pues bien está hecho en hungría con este
ejemplo ya os podéis hacer una idea de
que ojo la economía de hungría tiene
mucho potencial por ejemplo tienen un
sector importante pero también un sector
farmacéutico y una industria muy
importante
dicho de otra forma no es un país rico
como puedan ser alemania o suecia pero
si es una de las economías más
comunistas más exitosas casi al nivel de
polonia o república checa ahora bien
cuando orbán llegó al poder la situación
era muy distinta hungría atravesaba una
enorme crisis económica corría el año
2010 y hungría era uno de los países más
afectados por la gran crisis financiera
tenían un 11 por ciento de paro la tasa
más alta junto a españa y un 7 por
ciento de déficit público una cifra muy
por encima de los requisitos exigidos
por europa
vamos que orbán tenía un montón de
trabajo por delante y cuál diría es que
fue su receta para salvar la economía
pues podríamos decir que viktor orbán
hizo lo opuesto a lo que había cualquier
gobierno de centroizquierda vamos a
decirlo claro orbán es ultranacionalista
y no les gusta mucho que vengan personas
del extranjero ahora bien cuando
hablamos del dinero la cosa cambia
totalmente básicamente la receta de
orbán tiene dos pilares reducción del
gasto público y alfombra roja el capital
extranjero y en este aspecto hay que
reconocer que hungría es todo un caso de
éxito atentos a esta gráfica
[Música]
os fijáis veréis que hungría es capaz de
atraer más dinero del extranjero que
otros países como alemania o polonia
casi el 75 por ciento de la inversión
industrial en este país viene del
extranjero y tras la llegada al poder de
orbán este país ha registrado sus
mayores picos así que la pregunta es por
qué que tiene hungría que no tengan
otros países la primera respuesta son
impuestos si habéis oído bien si
pensamos en países con impuestos bajos a
todos nos viene a la cabeza a irlanda o
luxemburgo pero lo cierto es que hungría
tiene el impuesto de sociedades más bajo
de toda europa fijaos en este mapa
desde el año 2017 de las empresas
húngaras pagan un simple 9 por ciento de
impuestos de sociedades a todo esto hay
que sumarle toda clase de programas de
subsidios y deducciones fiscales por
ejemplo si una empresa reinvierte sus
beneficios en startups húngaras pueden
llegar a ahorrarse hasta un 80 por
ciento de impuestos si a esto le sumamos
que hungría tiene mano de obra bien
formada y sueldo relativamente baratos
es fácil entender por qué este país no
deja de atraer dinero del extranjero
para que os hagáis una idea son el
segundo país de toda la unión europea en
atraer inversión de un país como corea
del sur ojo esto no significa que corea
del sur sea el principal inversor de
hungría ni muchísimo menos pero os lo
pongo como un ejemplo para ver cómo las
empresas de países tan remotos como
corea del sur apuestan por hungría mucho
más que por otros países vecinos dicho
de otra forma si es verdad viktor orbán
puede ser la oveja negra de la familia
brush elita pero los resultados de sus
políticas no son tan malos es verdad
puede que orbán sea el hombre que haría
llorar a greta a amber pero cuando las
empresas que fabrican coches eléctricos
eligen un destino para sus fábricas
prefieren hungría antes que muchos otros
países
nunca
habéis oído bien desde el año 2021 de
hecho hungría se está colocando a la
vanguardia del coche eléctrico al menos
en europa atentos sk innovation
construirá su tercera planta de baterías
en hungría
bmw construya una planta de mil millones
de euros para fabricar coches eléctricos
enfría
mercedes benz e lanzara la producción en
serie de un vehículo puramente eléctrico
en hungría ella sé lo que estará
pensando alguno bien hungría puede ser
un paraíso para las empresas pero de
verdad todo ese dinero llega al bolsillo
del húngaro de a pie pues los datos
hablan por sí solos voy a daros una
comparativa en el año 2010 españa tenía
un desempleo del 19 por ciento mientras
que hungría estaba en el once por ciento
diez años más tarde 2020 españa todavía
seguía en un 15 por ciento mientras que
hungría apenas superaba el 4 por ciento
de paro no sólo eso todo este
crecimiento económico se ha traducido en
más dinero para el estado y cuentas más
saneadas y grace en qué se ha gastado
todo ese dinero cómo funcionan las
políticas sociales de viktor orbán pues
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
bueno
valores familiares
ya sé lo que estáis pasando muchos
viktor orbán no es más que un populista
de derechas toda su política económica
se puede resumir en una cosa bajar
impuestos así cualquiera tiene contentos
los ciudadanos y pues lo cierto es que
no de hecho si tuviéramos que definir de
algún modo la política fiscal de hungría
sería como anti populista si es cierto
las empresas pagan menos impuestos que
en ningún otro país europeo pero
recordad que las empresas no votan sin
embargo casi todo el esfuerzo fiscal
recae en el ciudadano medio y diréis
como pues con el impuesto más impopular
que existe el iva y los impuestos
indirectos porque si amigos de visual
politics y hungría tienen los impuestos
de sociedades más bajos de europa en lo
que impuestos indirectos se refiere es
todo lo contrario 27 por ciento habéis
oído bien mientras la mayoría de los
países europeos tienen un 21 por ciento
de iva hungría tiene un machacante 27
por ciento podréis criticar a esta
política pero desde el juego no podemos
decir que es un intento de comprar a los
votantes porque más bien pasaría por
todo lo contrario
pero ahora la pregunta es a dónde va
todo ese dinero que se recauda en
políticas sociales hay en hungría pues
aquí es donde podríamos hablar de una
especie de
socialdemocracia conservadora aquí es
donde orbán muestra su cara más
tradicional porque casi todas las
políticas sociales en hungría están
orientadas a un único gol tener más
hijos si habéis oído bien la crisis de
las pensiones es un problema en toda
europa incluida a hungría y la receta de
orbán para evitar el decrecimiento
demográfico se basa en intentar por
todos los medios que los húngaros se
pongan a tener hijos
[Música]
por ejemplo desde el año 2012 las
familias con más de 4 hijos no pagan
impuestos de la renta así tal cual 0% de
impuestos de la renta pero no sólo eso
dentro de la pareja la madre que ha dado
a luz cuatro hijos y está libre de pagar
impuestos para toda la vida y qué pasa
con las familias que no tienen cuatro
hijos pues por ejemplo las familias con
entre tres y cuatro hijos que compran
una furgoneta tienen una subvención de
alrededor de siete mil dólares
[Música]
en otras palabras que la política de
orbán es extremadamente social si
ciertos son ayudas sociales
condicionadas a tener hijos pero son
ayudas que llegan a la amplia mayoría de
los húngaros y no creáis que hablamos de
poco dinero en 2019 los llamados planes
de protección de la familia llegarán a
suponer el 48 de todo el pib húngaro y
la pregunta que ahora os estaréis
haciendo es vale pero de verdad están
funcionando estas políticas de verdad
hungría está consiguiendo acabar con el
invierno demográfico y la respuesta es
que no atentos a esta gráfica
aquí podéis ver como la tasa de
fertilidad de hungría sigue
prácticamente igual con o sin políticas
de natalidad las mujeres húngaras tienen
una media de 16 hijos en otras palabras
que la población húngara sigue
decreciendo ahora bien en lo que a
reducción de la desigualdad se refiere
tenemos que reconocer que orbán es todo
un genio atentos a esta gráfica
[Música]
aquí podéis ver como las diferencias
entre ricos y pobres son mucho más
suaves en hungría que en francia o
alemania ojo esto no es una apología de
orba ni mucho menos ya sabéis lo poco
que nos gusta visual politics sus modos
autoritarios su falta de respeto a la
libertad de medios sus continuas
agresiones a la independencia judicial
por su postura casi profusa durante la
guerra de ucrania pero esta es por así
decirlo una de las facetas de la
política un gran menos conocida y de la
que menos se suele hablar y por eso la
hemos querido contar
[Música]
y es verdad nunca veréis a orbán en la
cabalgata del orgullo gay su retórica
está muy lejos de lo que en cualquier
otro país entendería por política social
pero en nadie puede negar que su
gobierno está haciendo todo lo posible
por ayudar a las familias más
desfavorecidas y eso se nota en las
elecciones y ya sé lo que estará
pensando alguno a estas alturas o dios
mío en visual política estamos poniendo
a orbán por las nubes no será que es el
gobierno de hungría el que nos está
pagando bajo cuerda
tranquilos ahora os vamos a contar la
otra cara de orbán la que no cuentan ni
los medios húngaros ni tampoco los
medios mainstream atentos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el hombre que creó a george soros
georges horas es algo así como unas
vísperas ley de las conspiraciones no
hay teoría de la conspiración donde no
aparezca el nombre de soros por algún
lado probablemente todos los que veis
este vídeo le habéis oído aumentar en
algún momento la pregunta es por qué es
tan famoso me explico es verdad que
george soros es un multimillonario con
muchísima influencia política todo eso
es cierto pero no es ni el más rico ni
tampoco el más influyente así que porque
todo el mundo conoce a soros y no por
ejemplo los hermanos koch la respuesta
está en viktor orbán o más bien en el
estratega político que creó el mito de
viktor orbán y diréis pero qué tiene que
ver este buen señor con orbán o con
soros pues veréis la carrera política de
orbán tiene dos etapas bien
diferenciadas desde el año 1998 hasta
2002 viktor orbán fue primer ministro de
hungría en este caso podríamos definirlo
como un político liberal sin embargo en
2002 perdió las elecciones durante ocho
años estuvo en la oposición y ahí es
cuando contra todos los servicios de
artur finkelstein arturo finkelstein era
un consultor de comunicación política de
los eeuu mejor dicho podríamos decir que
tanto artur finkelstein como call row
waters son algo así como el frank
sinatra dean martin sammy davis junior
de la consultoría política unos
auténticos genios del arte de ganar
elecciones
[Música]
[Aplausos]
pues bien finkelstein fue quien dibujó
la nueva imagen de orbán un hombre del
pueblo que pasa los fines de semana en
el campo y bebe pálinka pero como ya
sabéis los que seguís visual política
desde hace tiempo para crear un eros en
política hay que crear un villano y
quien era el villano perfecto para orbán
pues nada más y nada menos que george
soros aunque no sea el inversor más rico
del mundo ni muchísimo menos nació en
hungría y tal vez sea el húngaro más
rico del mundo y el odio contra los
millonarios es un arma electoral tan
antigua como las promesas imposibles de
cumplir a esto hay que sumarle que
siempre ha sido crítico con orbán y que
además es judío lo que agita el fervor
antisemita de los húngaros en otras
palabras sólo será el villano perfecto y
eso explica declaraciones como esta en
un discurso orbán ataca al enemigo que
especula con dinero orbán europa no debe
sucumbir a los represores por cierto que
si queréis comprender más toda esta
historia de quienes de verdad george
soros y cómo se creó el mito hemos
sacado un vídeo exclusivo para patrián
donde lo tratamos en profundidad así que
ya tenéis otra razón más para entrar en
nuestra comunidad de patrón pero
volvamos con nuestra historia porque hay
otro as que orbán se guarda en la manga
arma electoral para ganar elecciones
no era de hungría y más de 24 millones
de húngaros étnicos es decir en rumanía
eslovaquia y eslovenia hay muchas
comunidades de húngaro parlantes durante
años ahora les ha dado pasaporte para
que puedan votar en las elecciones y
todos ellos votan masivamente al partido
de orbán el fidesz
y diréis es esta manipulación electoral
pues sí y a la vez no en cualquier caso
nadie puede negar que orbán conoce muy
bien a su votante por ejemplo en un
momento donde todo el mundo parece estar
muy concienciado con la guerra de
ucrania orbán ha sabido hacer una
lectura tan arriesgada como certera
rompiendo filas con la unión europea y
está lista para pagar el gas ruso en
rublos exacto hungría es el país de la
unión europea más cercano a la rusia de
vladimir putin desde el punto de vista
ético es una auténtica vergüenza pero
los números están ahí el votante medio
en hungría ha votado con el bolsillo y
la cercanía de orbán computing se
traduce en gas y petróleo más barato que
en cualquier otro país europeo al menos
en el corto plazo y diréis que puede
pasar en el largo plazo pues aquí es
donde llega el gran problema de la
sorbonne o mick porque durante años
budapest ha tensado la cuerda con
bruselas y su postura en la guerra de
ucrania podría ser la gota que colme el
vaso puede la unióneuropea sancionar
hungría vamos a volver a echar un
vistazo a esa gráfica de la inversión
extranjera directa
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]
si os fijáis en el año 2004 hay un salto
sustancial en la cantidad de dinero que
llega a hungría que pasó en 2004
exacto hungría entró en la unión europea
las empresas del resto de europa son las
principales inversoras en hungría en
otras palabras que el éxito político y
económico de orbán está atado a estar en
la unión europea la pregunta es qué
puede pasar si todo este grifo de
inversión se corta de golpe hasta qué
punto la postura de hungría con la red
ucrania puede ser el principio del fin
de la era orbán podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis que aquí en visual
politics sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribimos a este canal
y dadle a la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones
recordad también que tenemos contenido
exclusivo newsletter y merchandising en
nuestra comunidad de patrián si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un abrazo y hasta
pronto